later on today we're going to be
speaking with political scientist Rachel
bidikoffer and one of the questions that
I will have for Rachel is are the
numbers that increasingly suggest this
might not be a disastrous midterm for
Democrats are they numbers that can be
trusted because we're getting more and
more of these numbers now you might
remember that last week or the week
before maybe it was I told you that for
the first time in this primary season in
the 538 forecast for the U.S Senate
Democrats became favored to retain
control now it was a very small margin
it was 52 to 48 meaning if you run a
hundred simulations with the current
inputs in 52 of them Democrats end up
controlling the Senate and in 48 of them
Republicans end up controlling the
Senate
um we this is sort of like if you had a
coin that instead of being a 50 50 coin
was a 5248 coin meaning the more times
you flip it the closer you'll get to 52
heads and 48 Tails now if you only flip
it once it's either going to be heads or
tails and 52 to 48 is a very very small
margin in favor of of heads but the the
more times you run the simulation the
closer to 52 you will get that's the
idea here those numbers have now grown
to 57 in the exact same 538 forecast and
in fact Nate silver put together an
article on 538 which you can check out
which has a bunch of different data the
article from a few days ago called the
political environment might be improving
for Democrats and indeed when you look
at how the Senate forecast has changed
if you looked in at the beginning of
June
Democrats only had about a 40 to 45
percent shot at holding the Senate
remember Democrats currently have the
Senate 50 50 with the vice president
Kamala Harris as the tie-breaking vote
in the event of a 50-50 tie those
numbers have increased increased
increase to where now it is a 57 chance
that Democrats control the Senate after
the midterm elections and only a 43
percent chance that Republicans control
it now as we know
even things that are statistically
unlikely sometimes happen going into the
2016 presidential election the odds were
that Hillary Clinton had an 85 percent
chance of winning and Donald Trump had a
15 chance of winning now 85 percent is
not a hundred percent you run 100
simulations in 15 of them Trump would
come out the winner and indeed he did
this is a very very small margin but we
have to it's not even really come to
terms with it's understand that there's
a unique or at least an unlikely an
uncommon opportunity this November
normally and I know you guys or some of
you are sick of hearing this normally
when one party takes the White House in
the first midterm election they lose the
house and or senate or if they already
don't have control of the house they
fall even further behind or if they have
control of the house and retain it it's
by a smaller margin you get the point we
might not see that this November and if
the question is why which is to me the
most interesting question right now
everything we know everything we can say
is that it's because primarily of two
issues number one abortion and number
two gun safety although I have to say
compared to six eight weeks ago the gun
safety issue is not nearly in the
Forefront as much as it was but we have
two issues that normally are not good
issues for Democrats to run on that are
helping Democrats right now the country
MO mostly wants abortion to be legal in
most cases we saw that on Tuesday night
in Kansas
where Kansas voters voted to defeat an
amendment which would have allowed
completely Banning abortion they voted
to defeat that amendment by a 20-point
margin that is not a small margin and
that's a very red State one of the
reddest states in the country and when
Roe v Wade was overturned by the Supreme
Court even many centrists and
center-right people said that this is
wrong this is wrong abortion should be
legal in most cases and that may not
help Republicans in November in fact it
could be their undoing and in addition
to that although I think it's
diminishing compared to a couple of
months ago continued mass shootings and
just absurd reactions from Republicans
oh it's the issue is doors armed
teachers put more guns in the schools
ballistic backpacks and uh Bob grenade
resistant blankets or whatever it was
that was being proposed
outrageous and although there are still
many millions of True Believers who
think the solution here is more guns
certainly not to restrict access to guns
more and more of the country supports
all sorts of Common Sense gun safety
regulations we've looked at the numbers
overwhelming support for background
checks in all cases even personal
transfers and sales gun show every every
situation there should be a background
check and I've given you the list but
our elected officials by and large don't
support these things at least not the
Republican party this really seems to be
hurting Republicans and this is why now
in what should be
a really big defeat I mean by all
historical assessments democrats should
get crushed in November
it's increasingly looking if we had to
just say what's the most mathematically
likely scenario the most likely scenario
is Democrats lose the house but not by
much and Democrats maintain control of
the Senate now it might not go that way
we all must vote we must get involved we
must phone bank all of the things right
we're going to be talking about them
because it could come down to one race
and the Senate it really could come down
to one race
um we are going to continue talking
about it but the inevitable massive red
wave that many had been touting for a
long time since Joe Biden was sworn in
that massive Red Wave seems increasingly
unlikely